andrew do you think that's a good idea
having been in business yourself you
know there's
uh there's different number ones number
twos number three's number fours and
number fives and companies right and
somebody may be a good number one of a
10 million auto company but they're
number eight of 100 million dollar
company somebody may be a number one of
a hundred million dollar company but our
number four of a billion auto company
somebody may be number one of a billion
dollar company but a number two of a 50
billion auto company like there's levels
to life right
do you see yourself as a number one of
the united states of america can you see
yourself being the number one decision
maker president
of the united states of america oh yeah
i can see that for sure and i can see
that even more so frankly having been
around other people
that maybe have actually
had that responsibility uh and this is
probably something common to a lot of
entrepreneurs but you trust yourself in
your own judgment more than you trust
other people's you'd rather be
responsible for your own destiny you
know what i mean like you and now i will
also say that i've been in situations
where i'm very very happy to entrust uh
the responsibility of someone else who's
better situated you know like if you're
on safari and there's like a freaking
guide you're like hey
like let me
give this to you but uh you know i i i
have a lot of confidence in my own
uh we said something in my own ability
to make decisions i want to hear a
little more so he said i
if you saw some people that i saw i
fully have more confidence than being
being number one what did you see that
got you to be more confident about being
a good number one well this is one of
the reasons i ran for president uh pat
you've had this experience too i think
because of the fact that you've met so
many of us over this time so i started
an organization called venture of
america to train entrepreneurs and
during that time i met
you know three former presidents 20
senators governors members of congress
and after you have that experience uh
you don't come away necessarily thinking
wow these people are all amazing and are
capable of doing things i could never do
like instead you're like you know what
like i think i actually have you know
like the same level of uh overall
ability or competence or in some cases
frankly a bit higher i
addressed a group of entrepreneurs that
like ypo uh you know like uh or eos
organizations yeah these like
you know ass kicking entrepreneur types
and i said something to them that was
honest and some people can judge me for
this but whatever i was like i would
trust these 30 ceos in this room
more to run the country than the people
who are currently actually doing so you
know what i mean because if you had like
a bunch of number ones of significant
organizations the way you're describing
pat i mean they make these decisions
every day
they're really
results-driven uh they're good at
building teams they can like develop
cultures and then you are around the
folks in dc and a lot of those people do
not have that experience or set of
qualities a lot of these political
figures have never run anything
and then you you and then we're judging
them not based on whether they can
operate but whether they can operate
politically whether they can just show
up uh you know there's a chapter in my
last book called priests of the decline
where like you know it's like we we've
reduced political figures to folks who
just make us feel a little bit better as
we go home uh and the problems don't get
solved like that that's what we reduced
folks to
so uh you know i i know what makes me
tick like you know if i got in there i'd
be like look i'm going to solve as many
problems as i can
and if you didn't like it then you can
vote me out and i'll find something else
to do you know like a lot of these
politicians are addicted
to the field the job if they don't have
that attention they wither you know
that's not what makes me tick at all
which i believe would make me a better
figure to actually make some of these
things happen yeah do you uh do you do
you think and uh by the way great answer
appreciate you for that but do you think
uh like i thought you were gonna say
like if i hang out with some of the
people i got a lot of confidence i can
be a number one i thought maybe we're
gonna say joe biden gives you a lot of
confidence because his videos on c-span
i'm sure they're very inspirational for
you but going back to going back to uh
this whole topic here being a great
number one if you can smile it's okay if
you want to smile like that's okay every
once in a while i tell funny jokes but
do you think do you think your
ability
to
get dirty because it's very dirty you
seem like a really nice guy okay
and your answers are
if this is like pushing the envelope
where trump's gonna be bam bam bam bam
bam pushing the envelope if you know
clinton was not afraid to go bam bam bam
bam or even kamala hey uh you know vice
president joe biden i remember when you
were this and what you did with the bus
and holy [ __ ]
boom she goes here right
and i think when you did that with ubi
the idea was so crazy where the world's
like holy [ __ ]
that's pretty pretty crazy you kind of
poked a little bit but do you think
maybe you've gone a little bit safe and
a little bit too nice where you're
afraid to poke the bear to make a lot of
noise and maybe that's part of your
strategy i don't know maybe i'm wrong
again i'm just i'm just the business guy
i don't know what i'm talking about i'm
just simply asking questions from you
yeah you know about i i think different
occasions uh call for a different type
of energy i mean i've led rallies of
thousands of people and then you go into
rally mode uh you know right now i'm in
uh
in party building mode um which is like
look uh you know that we can sense that
this system is not working and our
children deserve better let's give them
better let's let's solve problems let's
give rise to a home for the people who
feel politically homeless
uh you know so there are different ways
i could make that case um maybe i'm
trying to make that case in a way that
people find like appealing and agreeable
and like you know there are other people
who might prefer more hey you know fiery
like uh you know the countries
uh heading off a cliff and like we need
to do something about which by the way i
totally believe i mean i could present
that case too
but
uh you know i think there are different
occasions different times but one thing
that people who know me know is that and
this is something you suggest a little
bit earlier i mean i run companies man i
mean when it's winning time you you know
you go for you go for the win like i'm
i'm not
uh here to mess around i'm here to save
the country if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]